When it comes to the ongoing anthology
series American Horror Story,
the amount of twists and turns and
time-traveling can get a little confusing.
So, we're here to help you make sense of
the entire American Horror Story timeline.
In the first season, Murder House, we learn that
famous Hollywood surgeon Dr. Charles Montgomery
built a classic Los Angeles Victorian mansion
for his wife, Nora, while they were flush with
celebrity money. But their fortune quickly turned
sour as Charles' mental illness and Frankenstein
complex forced him to give basement abortions
to make ends meet. The husband of one client
killed Charles and Nora's son in retaliation,
cutting him up into pieces. Charles stitched the
boy back together, along with other peoples'
parts, creating the monstrous Infantata.
Was it this grotesque series of acts that
turned the Montgomery House evil? Or was
the evil there all along? This question
has yet to be answered, but when Ben,
Vivien, and Violet Harmon move into the haunted
mansion in 2011, it's been home to dozens of
suspicious deaths. It's not long before the
Harmons realize the ghosts of those people
are very much active within the house's
walls, including their housekeeper Moira,
who appears to Ben as a seductive young woman
and to Vivien as a sad but helpful older woman.
And as if that wasn't enough for the poor
Harmons, Constance, Tate, and Addie Langdon
are nosy next door neighbors who constantly
appear in their house without invitation,
and they only hint at the house's sordid
past without mentioning their own role in it.
Plus, Tate is having therapy sessions with Ben,
and he and Violet quietly begin falling in
love until a new series of tragedies strike.
Ben has been unfaithful to Vivien in the past,
so when he shows up in a kinky black rubber suit,
Vivien thinks he's trying to rekindle the
previous passion of their marriage. Unfortunately,
it isn't Ben in the suit. The so-called "Rubber
Man" is actually Tate Langdon. And worse,
the Harmons find out that Tate is another of
the ghosts haunting the house, having killed
himself on the property after committing a mass
shooting at school. Creepier still, after getting
it on with a ghost, Vivien is suddenly pregnant
with twins, one of whom is decidedly not human.
"I'm sure you're aware that these babies, well,
rather, one of these babies, has
been developing at a rapid rate."
The human child is stillborn, and the
other is revealed to be the Antichrist,
born from spirit and flesh as prophesied
by the psychic Billie Dean Howard.
The hits for the Harmons don't stop there.
Tate convinces Violet to overdose on sleeping
pills so they can be together forever.
She and her parents don't realize she's dead until
she tries to escape Murder House and can't leave.
We then learn that Tate had hidden
her dead body underneath the house.
Sadly, Vivien dies during childbirth, a birth
overseen by the ghost of Charles Montgomery,
and she becomes a new addition to the house. She
tells Ben to take the surviving child and escape,
but the ghost of Ben's lover, Hayden, kills him
before he can. Constance Langdon takes the baby,
her grandson, instead. Of course,
there are no happy endings here,
as the first season of American Horror Story
ends three years later, with Constance finding
that her infant grandson has brutally killed
his nanny and is playing with her blood.
Set mostly in 1964, second season Asylum starts
off with Kit Walker, a man who's kidnapped by
aliens. After his wife and friend disappear,
Kit is imprisoned in Briarcliffe Manor,
an asylum for the criminally insane where the
staff are more disturbed than their patients.
Headed by Sister Jude, Briarcliffe is a
religious institution that handles its
vulnerable patients with more torture than
care. Many of the patients aren't even the
criminals they've been painted to be, like Pepper,
a gentle, non-verbal, microcephalic woman falsely
accused of killing a baby, as well as promiscuous
Shelley, whose husband locked her up for cheating.
On the medical staff are Dr. Oliver Thredson, in
charge of counseling, and the sadistic Dr. Arden,
a Nazi doctor who's performing horrific
experiments on Briarcliffe residents.
Meanwhile, Lana Winters is a young gay journalist
who's been searching for her big break.
Since lesbianism was considered a mental
illness at the time, Lana gets herself
committed to Briarcliffe to produce an
exposé about its gruesome ongoing events.
She discovers that Dr. Thredson is Bloody Face —
a serial killer who's been sexually assaulting,
skinning, and decapitating women — after he
drugs and kidnaps her. However, she's his only
surviving victim. Why? Because she's pregnant
with his baby. Lana's story shocks America
after she exposes Briarcliffe and Thredson,
but years later, we find out that a Bloody
Face copycat who's been killing people at an
abandoned Briarcliffe is Lana and Thredson's son.
In the third season, Coven, New Orleans is home
to Miss Robichaux's Academy for Exceptional Young
Ladies, a boarding school for witches run by the
Supreme witch, Fiona Goode. Fiona has superpowers
that she wields for her own narcissistic
ends, rather than the good of her community.
Unfortunately for Fiona, signs emerge that a new
Supreme is on the rise as Fiona's health and looks
begin failing. There can only be one Supreme at a
time, and the old Supreme must die for the new one
to take the mantle. The most promising Supreme
candidates at Robichaux's include timid Zoe,
confident Queenie, self-involved Madison
Montgomery, and sweet Nan, until Misty
Day — an almost-killed swamp witch with a penchant
for Stevie Nicks — takes sanctuary in the Academy.
In the meantime, a group of witch hunters led
by Hank Foxx, husband of Robichaux headmistress
Cordelia Goode, is killing the new crop of
witches on their way to enroll at Robichaux's.
Old battle lines open anew when
Fiona approaches her nemesis,
voodoo queen Marie Laveau, to find out the secret
of immortality so she can remain Supreme forever.
When Marie refuses, Fiona releases the
serial killer and torturer of slaves,
Delphine LaLaurie, that Marie had
under her spell, wreaking new havoc.
As Fiona's powers wane, the
witches perform a series of
tests called the Seven Wonders to see
who will ascend the Supreme throne.
Ultimately, Cordelia passes all seven tests,
resurrecting Zoe who died during hers.
Misty Day ends up trapped in purgatory, and
Madison's narcissism gets her sent to Hell.
American Horror Story's fourth season, Freak Show,
keeps us in the South, in the town of Jupiter,
Florida, during 1952. Elsa Mars and her Cabinet
of Curiosities run a waning lakeside carnival in
a quiet town that loudly resents their presence.
The era of television is at its pinnacle,
and people would rather sit at home watching
the screen than the antics of freaks like
Lobster Boy Jimmy Darling, Ethel the Bearded Lady,
strongman Dell Toledo and his hermaphrodite wife,
Desiree Dupree. To drum up sales, Elsa goes
on a hunt for new monsters to join her troupe,
finding the wholesome conjoined
twins Bette and Dot Tattler.
However, Elsa's job gets even harder when serial
killer Twisty the Clown goes on a rampage,
leading townsfolk to think the carnies
were responsible for the gruesome murders.
More threats to the freaks emerge with shady
Stanley, who's buying and killing circus folks
to sell their bodies to a medical marvel museum.
Worse, a rich psychopath named Dandy Mott becomes
fixated on Bette and Dot, an obsession that
leads to him going on a killing spree that leaves
most of Elsa's performers dead. Fortunately,
Bette, Dot, and Jimmy escape and get married.
And for the first time, the show
makes direct references to another
American Horror Story season, as
microcephalic Pepper from Asylum
appears and reveals how her sister killed her
own malformed child and framed Pepper. Also,
we learn that Elsa's legs were amputated in a
snuff film by Asylum's villainous Nazi, Dr. Arden.
Inspired by one of the most famous serial
killers in American history, H.H. Holmes,
the fifth season, Hotel, takes place in James
March's Hotel Cortez in downtown Los Angeles.
In 1922, March builds his hotel with a series
of secret walls and basements so he can kill
and dispose of guests without anyone noticing.
March is also in love with a young actress,
Elizabeth, whose affections belong to
movie star Rudolph Valentino. So naturally,
March disposes of Valentino, but not before
Valentino turns Elizabeth into a vampire like him.
After March's death, he leaves
the Cortez to Elizabeth,
now known as the Countess, who
remains its owner until 2015,
when she's forced to sell to fashion designer
Will Drake. The Countess plans to marry Drake
and kill him to get her hotel back, but the
Cortez's ghosts — as well as other angry parties,
like her transgender bartender, Liz Taylor —
throw wrench after wrench into her bloody plans.
"No pity party in my bar!"
All the while, a serial killer is brutalizing
people based on violations of the Ten
Commandments. Detective John Lowe suspects the
killer is working from the hotel. Because he's
on the rocks with his wife, Alex, Lowe rents a
room to investigate. However, over the course of
the series, we learn that March had been searching
for a protégé for years, and by the end of Hotel,
we discover that Detective Lowe is the Ten
Commandments Killer. Alex has also become a
vampire, and the Countess entrusts all the
vampire children in the Cortez to her care.
We should also point out that Hotel has a
reference to the first season of American
Horror Story, as the Countess goes to the
Montgomery House to get an abortion. However,
the malformed vamp-baby lives,
and she tends to it to this day.
Playing on its own narrative tricks, sixth season
Roanoke explores the real-life disappearance of
16th century North American settlers through
an in-show documentary entitled My Roanoke
Nightmare — which centers around the testimony
of homeowners Shelby and Matt Miller, who buy a
rundown mansion in the North Carolina woods and
experience supernatural terrors. They chalk it
up to the inbred Polk Family who previously
owned the house. Matt's sister, Lee Harris,
comes with her young daughter Flora to help out,
and they all discover there are dark spirits not
just in the house, but also in the woods, and life
in their fixer-upper becomes a fight for survival.
My Roanoke Nightmare is the show
within the show that explores the
Roanoke events featuring the folks who
lived it from 2014 through to 2016,
along with reenactors to play Shelby and
Matt, as well as Matt's sister, Lee Harris.
The meta-commentary goes even deeper when My
Roanoke Nightmare producers decide to bring
the real-life Shelby and company along with
the actors playing them back to the mansion
during the Blood Moon. The Blood Moon is the
time when the ghosts of the area come alive
and perform a series of violent rituals headed
by the "first lady" of Roanoke, Thomasin White,
aka the Butcher. The original Supreme, Scáthach,
also manifests, ultimately possessing Lee Harris,
who proceeds to go on her own killing spree. To
save her daughter, Lee chooses to go with the
Roanoke ghosts, and the historical mystery
of the area only becomes more enigmatic.
American Horror Story's seventh season, Cult,
drops us into the suburb of Brookfield Heights,
Michigan, in the wake of Donald
Trump's inauguration in 2017.
Ally and her wife Ivy own a local restaurant
that's newly struggling due to divisive political
rhetoric that's led to a rise in hate crimes
against marginalized people in their town.
As a result, Ally's childhood traumas are
so severely provoked that her phobia of
clowns emerges with a vengeance, as well as a
serious paranoia that someone's out to get her.
Ally is far from wrong. A charismatic
but deeply bigoted and misogynistic man
named Kai Anderson feels empowered by the new
political regime and runs for public
office on an open platform of hate.
"I said there is nothing more dangerous
in this world than a humiliated man."
He's also the leader of a cult
that has been dressing up as clowns
and killing people around town. But because
nobody but Ally has witnessed the clowns,
these murders get chalked up to a variety of other
motives. Ally's past mental health issues make her
easy to gaslight when her wife comes out as one of
Kai's cult members. But in one of the more complex
narrative seasons with numerous plotlines woven
together, it turns out that Kai's sexist platform
was orchestrated by Valerie Solanas and her lover,
Bebe, in order to blast women out of complacency
and into political rage. Solanas, famous for
shooting Andy Warhol, is also revealed to be the
infamous Zodiac Killer who was never caught. After
Kai is killed, Ally runs for senate and wins,
ending the season with the suggestion that
she's become a new cult leader herself.
In the eighth season, Apocalypse, we learn that
Vivien Harmon and Tate Langdon's baby from Murder
House is Michael Langdon, and he's the Antichrist,
here to kickstart the end times. But first,
the Hawthorne School for Exceptional Young Men —
the warlock version of Miss Robichaux's Academy
in Coven — mistakes him for the most powerful
warlock ever known, one that might be the first
male to ascend to Supreme status. Michael passes
all of the Seven Wonders, and he even manages to
rescue Misty Day, Madison Montgomery, and Queenie
from their purgatories. In the years after Coven,
Queenie visited the Hotel Cortez and
has been trapped there ever since.
The actual Supreme, Cordelia Goode,
is doubtful about Michael's powers,
but when her own begin to wane, she wonders if
it's true he's next in line of succession. He
is not. And by the time the witches figure it out,
Michael has instigated nuclear war on a devastated
planet. But he was unable to kill all the witches,
and now, they're the only ones who can stop him.
Cloaked under an identity spell in Outpost 3
— the former site of Hawthorne School — the
witch Mallory is the up-and-coming Supreme,
whose powers almost match that of Michael's.
She's able to travel through time to 2015
and kill Michael before he properly comes
into his Antichrist abilities, halting the
apocalypse. Or so we think. Apocalypse closes
in an unspecified present where former Outpost
3 members Emily and Timothy meet, fall in love,
and have a baby. Like Baby Michael at the end of
Murder House, their child also kills the nanny,
suggesting that the birth of Satan
might not have been halted at all.
We also think it's necessary to highlight a
particular episode directed by American Horror
Story queen Sarah Paulson, where we are taken
all the way back to the beginning to fill in a
number of pending storylines. Following the witch
Madison Montgomery and warlock Behold Chablis,
the episode finds the Montgomery House in
a sad state. Upon discovering her grandson
was the Antichrist, Constance Langdon
killed herself there so she could be
with all the ghost children in the haunted
mansion, including the Infantata "monster."
The Harmons have retreated to their own
corners, with Vivien avoiding Ben at all cost,
and Violet refusing to have anything to do with
Tate Langdon, the boy she loved but who assaulted
and impregnated her mom with the Antichrist.
Thanks to Madison and Behold's meddling, they find
out the evil that had possessed Tate transferred
to Michael Langdon, and Madison helps Violet and
Tate reconcile, which is another strange and
rare happy ending in American Horror Story.
Madison also helps the housekeeper Moira — who
Constance killed decades before after Moira had
an affair with her husband — find her bones
and then be buried with her beloved mother,
finally letting her rest in peace. Now
that the witches own the Montgomery House,
there should be no new ghosts
created within its walls.
As is the case with many time travel narratives,
an entire plot arc can sometimes get dismantled
as the story moves between different realities and
potentially parallel universes. When Mallory uses
her power to alter time itself by going back to
2015 and killing Satan's son, it raises one big
unanswered question: How could time travel
affect the show's timeline as it stands?
Well, based on the years in which they take
place, the present-day events of Roanoke and Cult
might not have happened at all anymore. Of course,
the histories of the original Supreme, Thomasin
the Butcher, the Polk family, and real-life Matt
and Shelby buying the mansion could be retained,
as well as the flashbacks to Valerie Solanas
and Andy Warhol in Cult. But what stands of
the rest of these seasons is unclear until
we get more information in future episodes.
Might the election results of Cult even shift in a
world where a first apocalypse was nearly averted?
Or since a new Antichrist gets born
regardless, will the timelines play
out similarly to how they already have?
We can only hope new seasons will tell.
In many ways, the ninth season, 1984, was
something of a palate cleanser for fans of
the show due to its standalone nature as a
mostly straightforward slasher movie homage.
Following a group of familiar American Horror
Story faces in new roles at Camp Redwood,
1984 dove big into '80s nostalgia through the
secrets of Camp Blood and all of its many ghosts,
new and old. Eagle-eyed fans spotted many
references in 1984 that called out or back to
previous seasons of the show. From small details
— like Margaret Booth buying Briarcliffe Manor
from second season Asylum and the fact that
Mr. Jingles' cabin in Alaska is the same as
Kit Walker's in Asylum — to massive thematic
connections like haunted places where the dead
don't stay dead starting all the way back
in the show's opening season Murder House.
But arguably the biggest connection 1984 has to
the bigger arc of the narrative is its connection
to Satan and his minions on Earth, a thread
that, thanks to Apocalypse, Coven, and Hotel,
has become one of the fundamental pillars of
the entire American Horror Story tapestry.
In 1984 we once again meet the Night Stalker
Richard Ramirez as he forges new deals with his
master Lucifer as well as other dangerous
killer ghosts. Because we don't exactly
know how 1984 fits in with the changed world
brought about by Apocalypse yet, all we can do
is wait for future seasons of the anthology to
hopefully reveal more about the larger picture.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.